so now we've gone through the basics of
JavaScript syntax structuring and
interacting with JSON data and
requesting data from a server now we
need to talk about how to interface to
the browser more specifically we need to
talk about the Dom or document object
model the DOM is an interface to the
structure of an HTML document for
example the head or body element the Dom
allows us to access and modify our HTML
document dynamically using javascript
our game is primarily going to exist
within a single element the canvas which
we'll get into later but what this means
is that we won't have a lot of reason
too heavily access the dumb in fact
we're only going to need a few things so
let's take a look at a quick example
let's say you want to validate whether
users entered a valid password into an
input field here's how you do that using
the Dom API in JavaScript you can see
the basic HTML here with the form and
the password input and the submit button
and we have a script down here where we
start executing our JavaScript first we
have this document get element by ID
method what this does is grab a Dom
element of the given ID in this case
it's example form which is right here so
it would grab this entire form when it's
submitted we run this function in here
now you don't really need to worry about
the password regex too much we're
interested in this part down here now if
the password doesn't match then we
create a new P tag element assuming it
doesn't already exist we check if it
exists by again using the document dot
get element by ID method and checking
for the ID notify if it does exist we
use the document create element method
specify a P tag this parameter is just
the name of a type of element for
example p or form or canvas now we set
the text content of that P tag to this
bit here and we set the ID attribute to
notify that way if we submit multiple
times we don't simply create a new P tag
every single time finally we grab a
reference to
the body tag since the body element has
an ID of body we can do that and we
append notify to the body now if we look
at this in our browser we can see we
have an input form with a submit button
and you can see our basic HTML down here
however if we submit an incorrect
password press submit we can see that
this pops up right here which is the
text that we set our P tag to you can
also see that this P tag was created
down here with an ID of notify and the
correct text you can also see that if we
keep pressing submit again more P tags
don't get created since we made that
check